today we're checking out this LG
soundbar to go with my new LG TV this is
the s95 QR Soundbar and this has an
entire system and I'm so hyped to set
this up thanks to LG for partnering with
me on this video right now we're
actually in my podcast room that I have
turned into a podcast SL guest room in
my studio so I've got this pull out
couch I've got the TV set up so I've got
it nice and cozy if I ever have guests
that need a place to stay so they can
come here to the studio and I can just
kind of put my microphones away and it
turns into a nice little guest bedroom
guess bedroom slash cinematic sound and
television experience because with this
new Soundbar it's going to be so awesome
in here this also can double for when I
have late nights editing I don't have to
go home I can just sleep here so yeah
guests or
[Music]
me this is so
heavy this is
so awesome this room is going to be so
great I I think I'm moving into my
[Music]
studio here she
is look at it it's beautiful all right
everything is now unboxed let's put it
all
together
[Music]
so I don't have the speaker stands yet
so I'm borrowing these ones from my desk
just to see how I like them and how I
like the height and then I'm going to
update and get some other ones to really
set this up the installation of this
thing was so easy it was actually kind
of mind-blowing basically all I had to
do was plug the HDMI from the eor out to
the eorc in on the TV plug in the
speakers and the subwoofer and
everything just worked okay time to
calibrate them and see how they sound I
can't wait it's not everything's all set
up let's get this calibrated to the
space I'm so hyped our podcast studio is
finally coming together with this
Soundbar and TV combination we're able
to use a wow interface and we can
connect it to just using one remote this
will let you individually access each
speaker to make sure it's working and
you can even adjust the settings and
sound so outside of the app this allows
us to calibrate it to the room which is
very exciting because obviously if you
are in a larger room it will sound
differently so let's start the
[Music]
calibration
so now that everything is all calibrated
I went in and turned on the wow
interface and this will allow you to be
able to use one remote and control each
separate speaker just right here on the
TV so here you can see it brought up all
of the settings and you can see all of
our speakers individually what's great
about the wow interface is this will
allow you to only have to use one remote
control to not only control your TV but
you can also control your Soundbar at
the same time so as you can see here
this brings up our display which shows
us all of our connected devices you can
go in here and change the different
settings if you like except for me I
usually keep it an AI Sound Pro because
it usually sounds amazing but if you do
want to customize this further you can
conveniently use the single remote
paired with a wow interface to change it
to standard cinema clear voice pro
sports music game Optimizer or even Bas
blast so depending upon what type of
content you're watching you can
customize it directly for yourself or
you can rely on AI to do it for you the
reason this works so well is because
this TV and sbar are made to work
together in perfect synchronization ST
which might not be the case if you're
using a soundar from a different
manufacturer so the fact that this is
made by LG and made specifically for
this TV it's going to sound amazing
speaking of sounding amazing Let's test
it out it sounds so
incredible even though this room is Tiny
like this sound stage is massive it
feels like a cinematic
experience wow what's so special about
Wild Orchestra is that not only does the
audio come out of the surrounding
speakers and the Soundbar but it's also
coming out of the TV at the same time
this is really unique because usually
most sound bars and surround sound
systems will just replace the audio
coming out of the TV but this works with
it to enhance your sound even more it's
also pretty awesome to be able to
control this all with one remote as you
can see I'm going up with the
volume and down with the
volume all with one remote I was so
excited to check out this Evo G3 now the
panel is a 3840 by 21604 Ultra HD self
lit OLED my voice is all around me and I
feel so weird but it sounds so good okay
I need something with a little more
music all right let's turn this
up one
[Music]
[Applause]
remote this sounds so good and what I
love so much is the fact that I can only
use one remote this did come with
another one but since we have everything
all synced up I can control the volume
directly from here I can also control
the TV so everything is synced and
working perfectly now let's talk about
these speakers the s95 QR is actually
the world's first Soundbar with an
upfiring Center channel that lets you
hear dialogue and other mid-range sounds
way more clearly this makes for a super
clear dialogue and a really immersive
sound experience the sound bar has a
total of 77 speaker drivers and rear up
firing speakers for a full immersive
experience and supports IMAX enhanced
Dolby Atmos and dtsx formats this really
lets you experience the audio content
the way it was meant to sound powering
all of this is the alpha 9 AI processor
in the TV for automatic optimization of
the Soundbar sound quality so no matter
what you're watching the sound is always
amazing I also love that it's compatible
with voice assistants like Alexa and
Google assistant and it even supports
AirPlay 2o and on top of all of that you
can easily connect your phone via
Bluetooth I'm so excited about this new
setup and I can't wait to start
recording some podcasts in here and
maybe even have my first guest
experience this entire setup thank you
guys so much for watching I had so much
fun getting a chance to check this out
and I'm so hyped about my new addition
to the podcast setup if you guys want to
get more information about this Soundbar
I will put a link in the description